the historic juniper hill inn sits on a
hilltop above the quaint village of
windsor vermont
built in 1902 the country mansion boasts
28 luxurious bedrooms
and two grand dining rooms
it is filled with original works of art
and antiques all museum quality
antiques dealer robert dean ii and his
boyfriend ari nikki bought the business
six years ago i've always thought that
you should live with nice things if you
can afford them
i thought you'd like it the guests that
we don't want here are people who don't
have a lot of money the inn may look the
part but despite robert's dreams of an
elite country estate the hotel is barely
functioning
robert dean has no hotel or no
restaurant experience the prices may be
a little bit high for locals three
hundred and fifty dollars two night
minimum so that's seven hundred dollars
the lack of communication is very
frustrating where are you
i know the customers see that every day
i need my key too because at this point
i can't even get in my room okay with
bookings at an all-time low the hotel is
in serious financial trouble
but that doesn't stop robert from living
a millionaire's dream robert believes
this place is his
playground
[Music]
and a playground for his friends he's
gotta have a lot of clothes made by yeah
he comps all their meals and rooms but
we never get tips they're having a hard
time paying me because they give away
all of their money and food to their
friends showing off using this as their
private castle with hardly any paying
guests it's no wonder that this inn is
in the red yes we are losing money more
or less like 200 000 a year
i think that the place is going to be
closed and it's that's very sad gordon
is going to come into this place and say
this place is [ __ ]
if i don't stop this business from
bleeding money
it's doomed
i'd love to own an end in a setting like
this if you get it right you'd make an
absolute fortune
before i get to juniper hill i want to
find out what the towns folk think of
the local land
hello how are you very well and yourself
yeah rather you've been driving all
morning um does juniper
help in you're gonna love it it's
beautiful and reputation it tends to be
a little on the high end for our area
okay but i would love to have a place to
go to locally do they not invite locals
up there i feel um that i'd be
interrupting i feel like i'd be
intruding
everybody
what a shame
thank you so much have a great day and
you come to windsor thank you very much
indeed thank you enjoy your visit thank
you
here we are juniper hill inn now who in
the hell would bring an rv all the way
up here
and not stay in that stunning hotel look
at it
my god that's beautiful
wow okay around to the front door
[Music]
can't believe they haven't cleared the
snow for a guest to come in
[Music]
you're kidding me
it's locked that's not very welcoming
[Music]
why would you have a big mansion that
guests can't arrive through the front
[ __ ] door
jesus who wants to enter through the
back door
mr ramsay's here i need you to do room
one right away
[Music]
well at least this door's over
finally hello there how are you how are
you mr anthony black gordon please oh
that's right
i'm robert dean robert dean
were you over there i was at the front
door yes okay this is actually our
entrance and in the winter because of
snow really we have to keep that locked
because otherwise the snow load comes
off and kills people kills people yeah
it can have you killed anyone so no
where's all this stuff from
um
an aftermath of a antiques fair yeah
this looks like it could be a beautiful
room but you can't tell because it's
stuck with so much clutter that's the
reception desk no my god so what is that
that is our bar right now you are
kidding me this is the bar yes with what
that martinis martinis god bless him
huh made of pigs pig martini well we
have three rescue pot-bellied pigs you
have three pigs here right
what is that for
were you born with this in your mouth
yeah don't i wish honestly actually no
that was a gift from a giant so yeah
robert obviously loves to show off all
his expensive antiques but as a guest i
don't feel comfortable i feel like i'm
in the museum
this is the main formal dining room this
big chair here is for for one uh just
kind of we're known as a romantic
destination and uh just out of interest
well we would move the table move it in
for me please yes
wow so you've got a sofa
on the table we thought it was kind of
nice to have like a cozy banquette
oh
well three us presidents have dined here
oh really which ones uh teddy roosevelt
calvin coolidge teddy roosevelt died in
here wow i wanted to try to give him a
little bit of sense of the history but
juniper hill wow okay so that's the
dining room well we have two dining
rooms oh god you must be busy with two
dining rooms well i wish we were busy
bloody how
we have spurts of being incredibly busy
right uh where we lack is all the other
times really yeah
this place looks like a millionaires
mansion not a struggling business i've
got to scratch beneath the surface
this place per week is telling how much
we're lucky if we're doing you know 15
000 a month what does it cost to keep
the place open
30.
yup
so you're losing
200 000 a year
it's been a nightmare we maintained our
room rates thinking that the economy
wouldn't be this long a hall
we've all experienced those kind of
difficulties and myself including but
you you navigate your way out of that
recession unfortunately my partner lost
his job we expected him to have his job
for a little longer he must have gained
a substantial
payoff or retirement it's all been put
into this how much over a million
dollars a million dollars into this
already yes
and does he have an active role in the
business he tries to maintain the
accounting and he helps just about with
everything uh we're in trouble
trouble you'd never guess from the look
of this place it's more like buckingham
palace in the skid row
do you know what uh robert honestly i
like to go straight to my room if you
wouldn't mind please all right wow this
place goes on it does it's the largest
culinary revival mansion in new england
and more paintings and you're in the
maxwell have art suite which is the
original uh okay wow beautiful room
and uh uh
i mean this is uh
this is a beautiful room but
why is that smell i mean seriously it
it does smell
yeah it smells [ __ ]
i mean that is horrific oh my god it
smells like sewage
[Music]
i'm at vermont juniper hillian and i've
just met his owner robert dean ii who's
filled his hotel with expensive art and
antiques were you born with this in your
mouth but he can't fill his rooms and
his business is struggling you're losing
200 000 a year it's been a nightmare and
no wonder because although the room he's
put me in looks nice beautiful room it
has one major drawback
it smells like raw sewage
we had a plumbing issue and it's like
someone's shot under the bed and um
how much this room goes for
350 a night 350
a night for room that smells of [ __ ]
well you're kidding me we haven't rented
it though bloody how it's been out of
use for um four months four months yeah
oh come on it has been this is crazy it
is crazy it doesn't make sense i gotta
get out of here it stinks is there
another room yes i have room too bloody
how i didn't realize 350
to be caked in [ __ ]
[Music]
wow it's gorgeous and this one doesn't
smell like crap i'm gonna quickly uh
unpack and then i would um i would like
to have a um a quick bite of lunch okay
i'll tell i'll notify this what time is
the restaurant close for lunch well we
actually don't serve lunch normally
but we're happy to prepare you something
is that a joke we serve breakfast stop
stop stop stop stop you don't actually
serve lunch no the restaurant's closed
for lunch yes if someone requests lunch
we'll make lunch for them but could you
uh prepare lunch for me uh yes i can
i'll tell the chef please okay uh thank
you yes
not open for lunch gordon is gonna want
lunch huh gordon wants lunch
what am i supposed to do with that
information
hmm
that was a welcome breath of fresh air
on the back of that disgusting smell of
crap in that room i can't believe it and
the rooms are gorgeous and yet how could
you have a room that
has been smelling for months that bad
and then he sticks me in it
what i'm up in
despite the hideous smell in that first
guest room
i've still worked up quite an appetite
hello
hi how are you barbara barbara how
glamorous are you i'm nice to see you
i have a mad crush on good as he knows
i'm a cougar
how old do you know
last week i turned 70. you're kidding me
you
watch out joan collins i'm telling you
now
bloody howl
baba what's wrong with this place well
in a nutshell don't get any people
like pulling teeth to get my paycheck
you don't get paid it takes forever to
get my paycheck and when i do it's
usually something's left out well hold
on a minute you you don't get paid and
when you do not not on time we spent
supposed to get paid every two weeks so
would you earn a fortnight i made six
thousand this year
six thousand dollars a year
that's ridiculous you know you gotta
have the money flowing and it's almost
come to a standstill at this point my
last paycheck was 48
unbelievable robert's obviously got
enough money to fill the guest rooms
with fine art and antique furniture
but he doesn't pay his staff
i'm i'm starving what would you
recommend for the crab cakes with a
little salad so this is the dinner menu
okay because we're not open for lunch
right and the lamb sounds great as well
you want the lamb yeah all right darling
is this a uh prefix menu or yeah cause
there's no prices on here what sort of
restaurant doesn't have prices on the
menu it's like a club for millionaires
where if you have to ask you can't
afford it i've got a supplement of 15
for the lamb how much is enough charge
for the lamb is robert nearby
[Music]
how much is it for three courses 59
59
so if we had the lamb it would be 74.
people are horrified at the price of the
food this is why a lot of people think
that juniper hill is snobbish when we
typically take a reservation we will
tell people it's a three-course meal
that's for the residents i'm talking
about a local coming in here we're
reservation only though so nobody walks
in we don't have to walk in how can you
expect to appeal to the locals um
we haven't identified the appropriate
people to come here or would you mean
appropriate people people who can afford
59 for three courses appropriate people
what a snob where does he think he is
the ritz
and where's your table which one's your
table uh well most the time i eat in our
rv
our motor coach say that again oh we
have a motor coach to the side price and
where'd it come from is it yours you
rent it yeah it's ours we i mean we owe
on it but we bought it and we bought it
yeah how much was that
over a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars
you're three years away from 50 you
should not be living in an rv
we don't
live in an rv um it is a motor coach
which is the higher end version of an rv
it is that psychological break for us
and it gives me a place to relax and
kind of unwind i actually love it i
could live there the rest of my life to
be honest with you it's quiet it's clean
i suppose if this place doesn't get
fixed then you might be in there full
time yeah
i've just sat down for lunch at the
juniper hill and already i've found out
the staff aren't paid on time like
pulling teeth to get my paycheck and the
owners live in a camper outside
how much was that over a hundred
thousand dollars this place is baffling
i hope the food makes more sense
excellent
wow
where are the crab cakes
oh that's in there underneath there are
they mini crab cakes are we uh the chef
has decided that those are the size that
he needs to serve
i mean that tastes dreadful
that thing tastes sort of washy and
soapy
and twenty dollars for them
he's as cheap with his crab cakes as he
is with his staff
now for the lamb with robert's
ridiculous 15 extra charge
it's um a rack of lamb encrusted in
macadamia nuts uh fresh herbs
and a little bit of dijon mustard it's
served with a honey vinegar reduction
it's not even cooked properly
getting rested and i'll take that off
i always get nervous when you see white
fat like that
on the side of the chop
[Music]
is it to your liking
i mean
it's pretty raw in the center you like
the flavor of it though the honey garden
no way too sweet
i i'm i'm not satisfied with uh the
quality of the foods coming out of the
kitchen i believe our chef has a
learning curve to be where he needs to
be thank you
we just lost our other chef
why did the chef leave
supposed to tell you the truth right the
truth is all i want to know
why did the chef leave
well her paycheck
she put all her everything on her uh
charge cuts and and she just figured she
wasn't paid back for what she chef
bought produce she did she did
everything she was the best chef ever
wow that's dreadful
i'm starving um the peanut butter
chocolate decadence uh i could do with
some of that pick me up please
thank you
god i shifted left because you had to
buy produce on our own credit card i
mean this guy's priorities are upside
down
a bit like this in
okay are you ready
this he said
he doesn't care for the sweetness this
fat around it he didn't care for the
flavor of the honey gar
[Music]
wow thank you very much did you cut it
in half because it looks like someone's
taking it and where's the other half
gone uh it goes to the another person
who orders oh no i want my other half
74
this place is insane
listen half my dessert's missing if you
think i'm spending 74 dollars
for a dessert
that
is half cocked
[Music]
it's actually quite nice
there is hope i'm sorry
i'm going to say that that is not a
dessert that he made
bama made it no somebody else makes
desserts it's ordered like store-bought
like through one of our purveyors
what
where's the chef he's in the kitchen can
you get him out please yes
what
how you doing chef julian in my opinion
is not living up to his potential as a
chef he will try to cut corners and i
think gordon needs to know these things
i've just spent 74 dollars for three
plates of absolute dire dated [ __ ] food
[Music]
crab cakes yes sir you can't put two
little half testicle-sized [ __ ] crab
cakes that came from a can there's
bigger [ __ ] cakes chef at the [ __ ]
canopy party my lamb was cold in the
middle the fat was white it was like a
mouthful of sugar the best tasting dish
for me was the [ __ ]
chocolate peanut thing that i got served
half a portion that's not even made
[ __ ] in-house
what is this there's no synergy here
there is honestly a lack of
communication often sometimes when i'm
in the middle of doing breakfast service
for the 10 people that we randomly get i
get five texts from him asking me a
question
so why are you texting him if you have a
question i might maybe leave the rv and
come out and talk to him show me those
texts are you nitpicking are you trying
to control him are you no i'm trying to
make sure i i'm i haven't been sleeping
very well to be honest with you and uh
i've had i've been beaten down
i'll take responsibility for everything
that happens in the kitchen you don't
own the place you own it yet he's acting
more responsible
what do you earn a week if you don't
mind me asking a thousand dollars before
taxes 400.
jesus christ almighty
400 a week to be the head chef in a
luxury hotel that's insane i mean you're
barely surviving i'm i'm i don't know
that i'm even barely surviving if you're
not happy with your work environment you
should leave are you taking the piss or
is this just an abuse for you
what are you doing to these people
so their livelihoods this is your
responsibility
[Music]
rob's world
and you're in an rv a hundred grand
everybody is disgusted that you live in
that thing they really are
because it costs so much money and they
can't get their paycheck on time
well that is not the that is that that's
part of the issue we are surrounded by
wealth and reminded of poverty at the
same time because of that rv well it's a
symbol to me that rv is a simple
and it's a symbol that you're separating
yourself from everybody else i'd be very
careful about coming down on me too hard
[Music]
i'm telling you exactly how i feel and
how that means the people that i work
with feel let me tell you how i feel
when you're in your [ __ ] kitchen all
day long and you're on the goddamn
internet instead of actually trying to
perfect a menu and get a menu how long
did i ask for you to make a menu of your
own if i'm on the computer usually as
i'm trying to research menus research
ingredients give me a break i've given
you plenty of rings i work very long
days and i haven't been paid in three
weeks there's only been one paycheck
that i got on time almost the entire
staff is ready to walk out because they
are tired of not getting paid
anything to say
[Music]
no we do things oh please
it's my first day at vermont's juniper
hillian and the battle between the chef
and the owner i'd be very careful about
coming down on me too hard has turned
what should be a charming country inn
into a war zone
i'm telling you exactly how i feel i
work very long days yeah and i haven't
been paid in three weeks there's only
been one paycheck that i got on time
almost the entire staff is ready to walk
out because they are tired of not
getting paid
anything to
say
no
we're tired and half the team is broke
i'm beyond angry i'm beyond pissed off
well i just got a new [ __ ] ripped to
me gordon says that i live in a fantasy
world and
that uh
i live in a million dollar rv while our
our employees can't pay their bills and
all of this kind of stuff because we
don't pay them on time and they're all
complaining that they haven't gotten
their paychecks this time either oh they
haven't
and he said that everything is all about
me
i can't believe what a mess this place
is
i've got to get off this hill for a bit
there's someone i need to see hello is
that lidar
it's gordon ramsay i've got some
questions about robert and juniper hill
would you mind if i pop over for five
minutes please
[Music]
great i'll see you then
thanks
[Music]
i think the old chef that quit will be
able to give me some insight into what's
wrong with juniper hill
hello hi how are you
good to see you good to see you come on
in
give you a little insight to what it was
like actually working there i have to
say it was very interesting five years
uh things were going very very well and
then all of a sudden two years into it
they stop answering the phone
robert i think thought he was too
important to answer the phone or he was
too busy doing other things so
preoccupied and distracted very very
preoccupied and distracted and not
focused at all on maintaining his own
business wow i was getting cut out of a
living when they did all this stuff i
used to earn forty fifty thousand
dollars in one restaurant now i'm down
to earning uh 15. were you paid on time
um not very often
uh did you ever use your own money to
buy things all the time
and then i would have to demand to be
paid back or we weren't going to open
for dinner it's insane barbara has been
shorted checks a lot she's barely owning
100 a week yeah and he won't pay her and
then if he had a private party with all
his friends he didn't tip them
you're kidding me no
that's just disgusting i mean that's
where i draw that you can't do that no
you just can't treat people like that
now he's a confirmed snob and he thinks
he's above the town he thinks he's
untouchable
i'm here to make this place work um the
first thing i'm gonna do is burst his
bubble i'd like to be a fly on that wall
but
would you come back and walk through the
doors to have a look at it at the end of
the week and just come back for dinner
no no just one go or no i'm not even
interested in getting in i i just fear
getting in one more battle with aria or
robert and what should i have for five
years yeah do you think i've got a
chance of saving it the problem he has
now is nobody will work there you know
i'm there to get this place turned
around um those staff deserve a better
future they do you know i i feel
terrible for them um listen thank you
you're very welcome um appreciate your
time enjoyed it thanks nice to meet you
bye-bye
bye-bye
[Music]
how sad is that after five years of her
life dedicated
to the juniper hill
you know she won't even step foot
in the door she doesn't even see them
the old chef left because she couldn't
stand it and the current chef looks like
he's ready to walk too i wonder if
everyone here is feeling the same
frustration
what's wrong with the place what's wrong
with this place we're lacking uh
paychecks on time
paycheck you don't get paid on time
either no
basic suppliers we don't even have i
mean noel purchased guest checks for us
today so that we've been using scrap
pieces of paper
[Music]
first neighbors i'm ryan keith ryan
keith what'd you do i'm the estate
manager here i do all the maintenance on
the house i've done everything here
though that's why he likes me to spread
out my talents to try and help anybody
wherever they need help how's morale
not good
i personally haven't been paid since the
6th of january here it is the 1st of
february
that's nearly a month and
you pay the employees before paying your
bills when they've done the work that's
their livelihood i'm amazed you're still
here working as hard as you are because
staff
never needs to be treated like this let
me tell you
it's always as if what you're saying to
him doesn't get through because he sees
you as not an equal
he treats me like that and that really
bothers me because i feel like i've
contributed a lot it's actually pretty
degrading this is insane
i'm shocked with what i'm finding at the
juniper hill inn owner robert wants to
kill his chef how long did i ask for you
to make a menu of your own and the rest
of the staff want to kill robert how's
morale not good estate manager ryan has
told me about some of the problems
but now he wants to show me if you want
to see the root of the problem let's go
to the basement to the basement yes
please jesus what's in there
everything already
it's the majority of it is personal
items not even the shelves are all lined
bloody hell
look at this place
oh my god
look at this stuff
stereos wine racks quilts chairs tables
copper pans more chairs over there look
at these robert prides himself in having
to have the very best of everything
christ is enough in here to open three
restaurants is all this stuff still
brand new most of it is brand new
littered with thousands of dollars
robert's got so much stuff he could
furnish a dozen houses but he doesn't
pay his staff it's crazy
where are we going brace yourself we're
going up to the office
you're kidding me
oh no come on man
this is the office this is the office
you are kidding me not at all i wanted
you to jesus christ scares me half to
death oh my god this is insane it would
only take a day or two to sort out this
horde as heaven but robert's left it in
chaos no wonder he spends all day hiding
in his rv
this guy has lost the plot this is
disturbing
please tell me there's no more
yes there's more this is where the pigs
are kept
at least they look happy hey
pigs who live a life of luxury while
everyone around them suffers sounds
strangely familiar bloody hell
so the owners live out
the pigs live in
there's more
so check out the storage units storage
units you are kidding me no
oh my god
this one's all personal items oh jesus
i mean i swear to god it's like a
special edition of hoarders
i mean honestly
wow
[Music]
i'm in shock you know and this one
all of this entire storage unit is full
of chairs
[Music]
oh my god
look at this stuff honestly
i mean they must be packed with
thousands of dollars worth of hundreds
of thousands of dollars how much stuff
does one need
[Music]
bloody hell
i can't believe how much stuff robert
has bought he must have spent a fortune
i've got to meet robert's partner ahri
and find out why he's financing all this
welcome welcome my name's hari it's a
pleasure
please
um
my god so how much money have you put
into this business personally more or
less over a million dollars a million
dollars and how much have you seen back
nothing
it was all my my uh severance package is
my income that i when i was working and
then my retirement plans rabbit's
savings are in artwork and antiques i
have supporting this in with my my
savings
clearly this is a beautiful place but
putting your entire life savings into a
sinking ship is insane and with robert
at the helm treating his staff so poorly
i don't see things getting any better
robert is in a fantasy world and i've
been struggling all day to get through
to him
this place it's dreamland a playground
for your boyfriend
robert your biggest problem is not
juniper hill your biggest problem is
[ __ ] robert
i'm at vermont's juniper hill inn and
i've just had a difficult conversation
with robert's partner ahri who seemed
strangely unconcerned about how bad
things really are here how much money
have you put into this business
personally more or less a million
dollars
a million dollars and how much have you
seen back nothing
but i've tried to make him see who's to
blame for the problems your biggest
problem is [ __ ] robert
dinner time is approaching word has
spread about me being at the inn and the
place is bustling good to see you hello
there
nice to see you i'm learning a lot about
why the inn is struggling by watching
robert and ari deal with a new influx of
guests
anyone with any wrestler experience
would stagger the seating of guests but
as if they're just welcoming people to a
dinner party at a private house hello
there how are you robert and ari see
everyone at once yeah at the corner make
pretend you're back in 1902 it's meant
to be a relaxed evening
and that's the recipe for disaster for
chef julian and the wait staff
chef i'm making a change on 21. write it
down don't tell me just write it down
it's an order
are you guys kidding me with all these
orders who said everybody at once like
this
we don't know about pacing
who's writing the tickets jeremy now in
table four table five some of them have
names on them some of them do not who
wrote that ticket there's not even a
table number on there table four they
just got their lobster where's table 23
they've got i need one person at a time
i need less talking in the kitchen table
23 has got no
window eight people ask me for something
with julian haven't been slammed by the
owner's dreadful seating ahri isn't
helping the strained atmosphere with an
awkward art lesson and then like this
this is from 1800 and it was painted for
opera house because you know what it is
what is that come on everybody has to
know what that is it's a hannibal going
across the abs with the white elephants
everybody should know that
[Music]
on the other side of the house robert's
also busy giving a lecture this is one
of the original signs to the house
there's a lot of history here um teddy
roosevelt actually was best friends with
the man or a very good friend with the
man who actually built the house maxwell
ever
do you always get this backed up i mean
yes yeah when i have
poor seating
robert has groups of his friends come in
sitting him at once okay so you're
waiting for your starters then yes okay
well let me uh check on those for you
okay yeah
robert yes this ticket system is
bollocks
handwritten tickets no time on there no
proper dates no coordination
who trains the front of house team who's
in charge of the restaurant who is that
i would be the host and then you'll be
the host yes the chef takes over the
kitchen this place is such a mess
clearly robert has no idea how to run a
hotel
yeah
so you me too
trying to straighten out the damn drinks
because they lose that we lost 30
something drinks oh my god
robert we lost 30 drinks at least i
often find drinks not written down or
just a lack of follow-through and it's a
big problem when we're trying to make
money there's no communication between
the bar and the dining room so people
get served drinks but no one remembers
to charge for them but we're losing big
money no kidding and they're losing
their checks and i'm going crazy trying
to figure out a system they have hardly
any guess and don't charge the ones they
do have no wonder this place is in the
red how does that happen they're
supposed to write the drinks down and
then apply them to a table and a room
and then they go into the computer
the ticket system is bogus and as i
feared seating everyone at once is
already causing problems for the staff
and the
guests not very warm
it's burnt
with guests now suffering and the
kitchen falling apart from robert's
ill-managed seating come on i have to
step in
um just to just stop there
you have to be [ __ ] kidding me this
goose liver is burnt to a cinder stop
julian yes come around buddy i know
we're in the [ __ ] and we're busy food's
dying in the window
a foie gras salad
i mean honestly
it's like a piece of [ __ ] beef jerky
where's ari get me ari urgently
i mean honestly come on guys
hello i stopped that i just said
that is not progress it's not funny guys
oh that is not funny i mean i know we're
in the ship but does anyone have any
standards here
yes
well can i see them
can i see something to hold on to
because right now i just want to get out
of here
i can only be as good as i am with the
tools that i have i'm embarrassed and i
know that i can do better i know the
staff can do better first off no more
[ __ ] tickets in the kitchen give him
10 minutes to catch up okay all right
and robert is it possible for a first
time put the phone away get your jacket
off and [ __ ] dig deep a little bit
yeah please
yeah somebody i'm concerned that food is
in the window and it's just dying
entrees on table six are in the wind
entree send them they should be sat here
i mean how am i supposed to do
everything battery are you with me now
i'm with are you an owner i'm with you
are you an entrepreneur i keep trying to
you know you can talk to him he's your
[ __ ] chef well when i try to
communicate he says yeah yeah no no no
no no i can't do it no he doesn't
[ __ ] find your balls and tell him you
need to i found my ball do i want him to
walk out he's not going to walk out if
you communicate with him talk to him
there well i have been trying to so when
he finishes it
send the [ __ ] food there's always a
third dish not ready or a fourth dish
well it must be one or two minutes
behind but unless you [ __ ] ask how
are you supposed to [ __ ] know i have
been asking i said where does this
chicken go ask him again
it's the middle of dinner service at
juniper hillian and chef julian is
drowning under a flood of orders
how am i supposed to do everything back
here owner robert has finally decided to
get his hands dirty to try and help but
he's utterly incapable of communicating
with his chef
when he finishes it
send the [ __ ] food it's always a
third dish not ready or a fourth dish
well it must be one or two minutes
behind but unless you [ __ ] ask how
you're supposed to [ __ ] know
[Music]
where is the soup go jillian table 23 i
just told you one minute ago i need frog
bra i know i have it right behind me all
right well you see
okay julian yes that's what you call
communication
it's better communication that's what
you call communication roberts there's a
difference between interrupting
and no communication and when you
[ __ ] put those entrees up there you
make sure they go you've got to start
stepping up and [ __ ] dictating a
little bit because this is just madness
i agree
jesus christ it was fuck-ups
from start to finish and it was a
[ __ ]
and gordon saw that dreadful with an
owner and chef so incapable of
communicating with each other it's no
surprise the diners are unhappy and
they're not the only ones while robert
and ari are living the dream their staff
are living a nightmare
hopefully by gathering everyone in one
room okay i can get to the root of the
problem i've never seen a hotel and inn
in such disarray there needs to be
structure and there isn't structure
it's just like a scramble it's a mess
there was no order in the kitchen nobody
took responsibility for any one thing no
one has been taught any standards in any
department
really it's like i'm racing from thing
to think nobody knows what the other
one's doing there's nobody here that is
in control willing to take charge i did
40 [ __ ] dinners by myself tonight i
could help you and you've never asked i
can cook the rack of lamb excuse me
bragging about me one plate is nothing
to brag about excuse me excuse me i am
the boss you can't call yourself the
boss if you don't [ __ ] pay them
i mean honestly do you think that's
normal larry do you think that's the way
to look after your team every pay period
there is a problem with the checks every
pay period there's a problem with the
check i don't know what the problem is
but i know it's the same two people and
you get to know about it first or you
have to go ask him for your salary i
always ask for it that's absolutely
wrong and the reason is he's lying no no
no he's not lying i would rather have
them wait than write a check that's
going to bounce because i don't how
about telling him it's not gonna be
ready rather than having to ask like
some skivvy cap in hand please sir may i
get paid
anybody else have to wait yes
how long five days more
barbara i had to wait five weeks you had
to what i had to wait five weeks before
i got a paycheck five weeks
guys you come in and you work your ass
off
the least these two guys can do is pay
your [ __ ] salary on time i don't have
a secretary gordon i'm sorry i'm trying
to communicate with brides i'm trying to
send out things i have to have peaceful
time in order to do my work are you
always this pathetic i am not pathetic
well when are you going to stand up and
start showing some respect for your team
and start growing a pair to sort of
understand the measure in i understand
the mess we're in i'm fighting for the
team you dug the [ __ ] hole yes and
put them in it
so they're [ __ ] they don't have to
work here
oh my god you know the bottom line is
how dare you no they don't have to work
here
how dare you
how [ __ ] dare you they don't have to
work here oh my god
i i i disrespectful disgusting man
they don't have to work here
i don't think you realize
how [ __ ] lucky you are
because it wasn't for one two three four
five six of them you'd be driving that
rv
miles away from here
robert definitely needs a reality check
it's life or death right now and i don't
think he actually realizes what kind of
jeopardy this place is in it's not all
about you robert robert's world robert's
bubble robert's dream
you're not the lord of the manor and
you're not the great gatsby you're
you're you're robert it's only me in
here excuse me excuse me go on then you
pump as [ __ ]
excuse me
don't talk to me like what's wrong with
it i want to know don't speak to me like
well i'm telling you get your head out
your ass and start getting a little
[ __ ] real
you still haven't got it now this place
is sinking start paying a little bit
more attention to the guys on the ground
understand how hard it is out there
forget your [ __ ] antique roadshow
and start from the bottom running this
business you're right there's no
structure it's fragmented the team
needs a leader they need a structure
they need a mentor they need some
support
and all they get is nitpicks what kind
of motivation is that
all i've heard since i've been here
you're just blaming people
well i'm blaming you for not taking
charge get [ __ ] real
[Music]
you